hey guys this is Pete peppers and this
is a quick video about lives and how the
message box works and candy crush jelly
it's a mobile only game at least for
right now so it's a little bit different
but some people in the group are asking
so I'm going to just make a quick video
that you can watch so once a day once
every 24 hour period you get this option
to send lives you can select all
everyone that's your friend that plays
jelly saga will be selected if you do
that you can see I got a long list here
so you can do that once a day and that
sends I lives out to everybody that'll
take a second and it will it'll ask you
for permission to send all these people
lives and then the confusion that people
are having is based around the box and
about sending live so what I'm gonna do
here is I'm gonna clear off the five
lives I have I'm gonna pause just for a
second first I'm gonna send out to all
my friends who need help unlock in the
next episode that's gonna pop most
likely give me another pop up to send
these people their requests so I'm gonna
pause for a second and get rid of some
of my lives and then I'll be right back
okay so we're back here so whenever you
see the lives up here you see that you
know I have four because I got rid of
one and if you click on that it'll give
you the time to your next life or you
can ask friends so once again you can
you can select all your jolly friends or
you can you know take a couple people
off and you know if you know someone
who's active that you know you're asking
you can ask them I'm gonna go ahead and
hit Send select all and you know you can
see at the top here it says ask four
lives so that you're sending it okay
so the envelope box okay the problem
that you have with jelly and with soda
is for some reason I'll send out this
again is that you can't scroll the you
can't scroll to the bottom of this
alright so what we have in here is we
have a bunch of people that have sent us
lives right so we have this person plus
for the friends gave you lives when you
hit accept you can see that what it does
is it sends a live back to that person
all right so when I hit this everyone
who gave me a life gets a life back now
we got a really long queue here and the
problem with this is I'd haven't cleared
it out since I was playing the other day
from what this is is that anybody we son
lives to our request is going to go at
the bottom of there you know the life we
sent them is going to go to the bottom
of their list and vice versa so I know I
have a lot here so I'm gonna go and just
collect them all but keep in mind that
we're sending everybody a life right and
I might just pause it again because I'm
gonna clear all these so let's give it a
pause and I'll be right okay so after
accepting a lot of these you can see now
that there's a new box at the bottom
this is always at the bottom it's a big
mistake in the design but that's just
the way it works and so I'm still
sending lives back to people clearing
them all out and you can see
came back right at that time that I was
doing it but here these ones the one
that says Karenin 3328 other friends
knees lives those are the lives that
people that I asked people for when I
hit this ask friends button all right so
there's two different ways to get lives
there's way there's asking your friends
and then they're sending one to a friend
who will send it back when they collect
it and you can see that more or coming
back now that I was sending them out to
people because they're getting mine
they're using other than they're sending
the Mac so I'm gonna send these to the
328 people that are waiting but the
point is is if you're not getting wise
from your friends that's generally
what's happening is you ask for lives
and this thing is buried at the bottom
of their message box so they never clear
out because there's they're holding on
to their own lives rather than sending
them back and so they never get to this
part where they return it and you can
see when you have a lot of them in there
then it actually takes some time before
it even works so if they would have
clicked on it and then closed out their
game then those lives wouldn't go
anyways so I've always advocated in the
past especially when most people were
playing on Facebook rather than on
mobile and clearing this out every time
because all those people that use the
lives you sent to them will send them
back typically what happens instead is
people want to hold on to their lives
because they think oh oh I have like 500
lives and my my mailbox but another
thing to keep in mind when you're
talking about that is that whenever you
update the the game for the new levels
you usually lose those anyways so you
know there's a lot of people who like to
hoard those lives and never collect them
you know I kind of understand that but
those are the same people who wind up on
King care like complaining that they
lost all their free
that they got from their friends and the
idea is is that you're not really
supposed to sit around and hold on to
those at the same time you're supposed
to you know share lives with your
friends and there I just sent the 328
people on my left who need them
and so now my message box is empty so
I'm gonna pause it one more time and
then okay so I paused it one more time
and now I'm just gonna open it back up
and look inside and you can see that I'm
getting lives back already and I've had
20 p27 people request lives and I can't
even get to them again because all these
lives I just sent out are coming back so
you know there's two different ways you
can look at it you can hold on to them
you can never go down to the bottom of
your mailbox and never return your
friends requests I I don't like to do it
that way you know I obviously have a lot
of friends and as you can see my lives
will fill back up right away anyways you
know so in my group I try to tell people
you know to be thoughtful and send them
you know if you're not playing anyways I
don't see the point in trying to save
them all but um otherwise you can hold
on to him and you know wait til you play
again but you're just like yeah you know
just like remember that you know if
you're not if you're not using the lives
and people aren't getting the mic if
you're playing actively then you know
you're you're gonna be using the lives
you're gonna be sending them back but
you know it's not it's not the most
neighborly way to go about it so you
know if you're always sending them out
your mailbox should fill up pretty fast
just like mine is right now and I hope
this clears it up you know join our
group if you're looking for more friends
we have tons of people in there that are
looking for so two friends or jelly saga
friends the
the link is in the in the description
and subscribe to our channel leave a
comment if you have a question about how
lives work or anything else in jelly
saga and I'll try to answer it as soon
as I can
thanks